the heart center at Nationwide
Children's is dedicated to the unique
needs of patients with hypoplastic left
heart syndrome and other forms of single
ventricle heart defects if your baby has
hypoplastic left heart syndrome or other
single ventricle heart defects and has
had the hybrid stage one procedure the
next procedure will be the comprehensive
Stage two this is the second of three
surgeries the comprehensive stage two
procedure has two goals to decrease the
amount of blood the right ventricle has
to pump and to allow passive blood flow
from the upper body to the lungs the
procedure is usually performed at four
to six months of age if your baby had
the hybrid stage one procedure he or she
has bands around the left and right
pulmonary arteries and a stent in the
patent ductus arteriosus or PDA the
comprehensive stage two is open-heart
surgery to begin the surgeon will make
an incision in the chest once the heart
is reached your child will be placed on
a heart-lung bypass machine
next the surgeon will divide the main
pulmonary artery then the stent will be
removed from the PDA
the surgeon will remove the bands from
the right and left pulmonary arteries
and repair the openings in them next the
superior vena cava will be detached from
the heart and attached to the right
pulmonary artery
this new connection is called a
bi-directional Glen anastomosis it
allows oxygen-poor blood from the upper
body to get to the lungs without passing
through the heart first next the surgeon
will enlarge the opening in the wall
between the right and left atrium this
enlargement allows more oxygen rich
blood from the lungs to mix with the
oxygen poor blood from the body
finally the surgeon will remove the PDA
and begin reconstructing a new a Horta
the hypoplastic a Horta will be enlarged
using patch material the native aorta
will be connected to the enlarged aorta
this is called the de Miscanthus
anastomosis the new aorta allows
unobstructed blood flow out of the right
ventricle to the body it also allows
blood to flow into the coronary arteries
that feed the heart at the end of the
Comprehensive Stage 2 procedure an exit
angiogram will be taken the angiogram
will help the surgeon see how well blood
is flowing through the pulmonary
arteries to the lungs
our single ventricle team at Nationwide
Children's is dedicated to supporting
your child we are available to answer
all of your questions at any time at six
one four seven two two two five three
zero and at Nationwide Children's org
slash heart